right here in the lobby a financial
piece Plaza in Martha's place Britton is
with us I've written how are you hi they
better than I deserve
welcome welcome it's good to have you
where do you live Kansas City Missouri
fun and what are you doing in Nashville
Dave I am here to scream that I am
debt-free cool are you doing anything
else while you're here I am I am doing
something else so my dad is here with me
he thinks I'm here to scream I'm
debt-free for my consumer cards credit
cards in school don't school loan debt
that I paid off back on Christmas of
2010 I wrote him a check for sixty three
hundred dollars that was actually the
first time I became debt-free and then
three months later I purchased a home
and I'm actually here to tell my dad but
I have paid off my mortgage
Wow hey put dad on the founda
microphones with her right quick you
guys come on cat jump in there I turned
29 a few weeks ago well congratulations
and what's your house work 25,000 I
purchased the foreclosure loft in the
middle of downtown Kansas City what do
you make a year
I currently make about 70,000 when I
purchased my home I was making about
35,000 Wow you are awesome I mean boom
you got him all right dad what's your
name what's your first name son Larry
Larry welcome to welcome to our surprise
yes I contacted Kelly over the summer
and I've been planning this for a number
of months he actually didn't even know
until yesterday when we were standing in
the security line at the Kansas City
Airport that we were coming to Nashville
oh wow and then when we landed in
Nashville he asked me what country
singer do we get to meet because I told
him that I had won something and we got
to meet somebody special
to try to rustle you up a country person
and then he didn't know until this
morning when we were pulling into your
parking lot where we were actually going
so he doesn't know he thought I was just
here to scream off I'm got for you he
thought I had a mortgage so so Larry
obviously this is a big deal for you you
must have been talking her into doing
this for years you must because I mean
some people don't care they're like oh
well that's nice she paid it off but
this is obviously matters to you why why
well because as I've told several folks
I was my father went bankrupt and it was
probably the best gift he gave us his
kids and I've been debt-free pretty much
since that time I may have paid school
loans off early in business loans and
she came out of school with a surprised
debt that I didn't realize and I
challenged her she took the challenge
paid me off early and and we've watched
her grow ever since in her business and
her dealings
she's self-employed and and she makes
her own rules and we're just having fun
watching her grow yeah and this is so
it's a big deal this is legacy stuff
right here your whole legacy is shifted
well congratulations Larry way to go
Britain thank you so what do you tell
all the 29 year olds are out there going
oh you'll never get your house paid off
it's it's they're systemic problems with
the economy you can't win in this
economy you did different habits oh yeah
so um I think one of the biggest things
is um you know when we would go out with
me my girlfriend's just out and get a
good bite to eat or something my bill
would be five or six dollars because I
would be getting the cheapest thing on
the happy hour menu and drinking water
and my friends would be spending twenty
and thirty forty dollars because we were
getting the meal and the drinks and you
paid off your house I have you off my
house too I am it feels really good to
be weird awesome so what do you tell
people the key is if somebody hears you
paid off your house at 29 years old wait
you tell them what's your secret you
have to want it you have to sacrifice
didn't you I sacrifice and I had um I
have a I have a bigger why so so my why
is
I've been doing mission trips in Jamaica
for a number of years and there's more
that I want to do there and I and I I
needed to get to a certain point in my
life that I would be able that would
allow me to be able to do more down
there and this was what I really wanted
to do so I had a bigger wife for myself
I actually this was part of my wife so
when I when I really got serious about
this I built this little map for myself
and and every piece that I got colored
in or that I colored in was meant that I
saved another thousand dollars towards
my bigger goal okay there's nothing
stopping you yeah you've got you got
plans for money money's gonna be a tool
in your hands your whole life that's
excellent way to go well congratulations
I'm very proud of you all right Larry
you got this one man you're proud of her
aren't you
yes sir I am yes that's amazing way to
go dad excellent stuff you raised a good
one you raised a good one well thank you
all right Britton count it down let's
hear it
what's the total debt paid so it is
$50,000 and that's all in my mortgage
$50,000 in 33 months and you made 70 a
year I'm I started at 35 and now I'm
making 70 okay very cool and you just
lived on nothing to make this happen you
really did I pretty incredible yeah all
right count it down let's hear a great
debt free scream all right this one's
from my mom she's out there watching you
ready all right
I love it I love it that is fabulous
very well done